und jetzt dann heute der unvollständiges
Bild diesen Hinweis verschickt also die
Zeilen die geben ein unvollständiges
Bild ab überhaupt glauben ja dort
unserer Umfrage
57% der Deutschen sowieso nicht dass
diese Zeilen weil die da sind und
darüber müssen wir sprechen mit Hans
Ulrich Jörges gerade schon angekündigt
uns bei Bild live im Studio ein Aufreger
für so viele Deutsche so viele Vertrauen
einfach diesen Zahlen nicht was ist das
für ein Desaster in einer Krise in der
so viel um diese Zahlen und genau diese
Zahlen geht wir sind wir leben in
Deutschland auf einer Insel der
Ahnungslosen in Europa um uns herum
springen die Infektionszahlen in die
Höhe bei uns dümpeln die so vor sich hin
und das ist ja nicht nur in diesem Jahr
an dieser Jahreswende so das war er vor
einem Jahr ganz genauso und hat sich
überhaupt nichts verändert es ist sehr
viel mehr Geld zur Verfügung gestellt
worden damit die Gesundheits Bürokratie
aktualisiert technisch aufgerüstet
besser personell ausgestattet wird ist
es so gut wie nichts passiert es wird
immer noch mit Faxen gearbeitet es wird
immer noch Telefon aber nicht online
gearbeitet also und wir wissen so wenig
im Moment stimmen unsere
Infektionszahlen ganz bestimmt nicht
wenn sogar die Minister sagt die sind in
Wahrheit zwei bis dreimal so hoch dann
wissen wir nicht wie weit ist der
omnicon Virus schon in Deutschland
vorangekommen es wird bei uns zu wenig
sequenziert das heißt die Viren werden
zu wenig differenziert untersucht welche
welches Virus ist es überhaupt das
wissen wir nicht in anderen Ländern bis
die das sehr viel besser als wir und
dann Basti Infekt was die impf Zahlen
angeht also wir erinnern uns mal dass
Jens Spahn der alte Gesundheitsminister
Anfang Oktober verkündet hatte wir wären
jetzt bei 80% Impfquote das war die
Nachricht des Tages da sagte er schon im
Herbst und Winter sein keine weiteren
Einschränkungen notwendig und der Chef
der Kassenärztlichen Vereinigung her
Gassen sagte man könne jetzt die Corona
Beschränkungen aufheben das war Anfang
Oktober 80% inzwischen sprechen wir von
gut 70% da weiß man kann ich wie sind
die jetzt von 80 wieder auf 70% gekommen
sie trauen ihren Eigenwerten nicht was
steckt dahinter ich glaube diese
dreistufige Gesundheits Bürokratie in
Deutschland unten die Labore die testen
dann die Gesundheitsämter in den
Kommunen und dann ganz oben das RKI
funktionieren alle drei nicht und da
muss grundsätzlich was passieren ich
glaube es ist höchste Zeit dass der
Bundestag jetzt im Frühjahr eine
Kommission einsetzen
Untersuchungskommission könnte eine
Enquete-Kommission sein und die
Schwachstellen in diesem System raus
arbeitet und dann dran arbeitet dass die
behoben werden und ich glaube es wird
auch kein Weg dran vorbei dass das RKI
ihren neuen Chef bekommt ich glaube Herr
Villa ist durch wir haben ja schon am
Ende des vergangenen Jahres gesehen dass
er quasi gegen die neue Bundesregierung
rebelliert hat das war eine ganz
ungewöhnliche Geschichte das Vertrauen
mit dem Gesundheitsminister ist
zerrüttet und es wäre nicht schlecht
wenn er neues Gesicht da wäre das ein
neuen Anfang macht und die ganze
Geschichte von oben her neu organisiert
der Finanzminister Lindner hat jetzt
gesagt Deutschland müssen in der Lage
sein in einem Monat die gesamte
Bevölkerung durch zu empfinden falls ein
neues Virus kommt tolles Ziel mit dieser
gesundheitsbüro Kathi völlig undenkbar
da müsste viel verändert werden aber es
ist ein gutes Ziel dran zu arbeiten also
nehmt euch mal im Bundestag diese
Geschichte vor Anfang an die Mängel zu
beseitigen
das hat wird weil die Behörden die
Krankenhauseinweisungen gar nicht
aktuell haben und dann stellt man nach
einer Woche fest hoch die war ja ganz
oben relativ weit oben nicht soweit wir
fahren ja aber viel höher als die
aktuellen mitgeteilt wurde das heißt auf
der Basis der jetzigen
nicht funktionieren Gesundheits
Bürokratie ist die Politik im Blindflug
Stelle Manzoni
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit neuen
Beschlüssen am 7. Januar machen ich habe
gerade gestaunt und zwar gerade der FDP
General der künftige im Studio Bison dir
Sarah und der hat immer gesagt da kommt
doch die Zahlen bei Seite wichtig sind
doch die politischen Beschlüsse ich habe
es immer gar nicht verstanden hat geht's
dir geht's genauso es geht doch genau um
die Verknüpfung als die Politik sagt
doch er guckt auf die Zahlen und
deswegen machen wir diese Beschlüsse
also kann man mit solchen völlig
unglaubwürdige nicht richtigen Zahlen
über die der Gesundheitsminister selber
sagt die Stimmen nicht die sind viel
höher zwei bis dreimal höher kann man
auf Basis solcher Zahlen überhaupt
politische Beschlüsse treffen jedenfalls
kann man keine weitreichenden Beschlüsse
fassen auf Basis Feuerthalen das ist
auch schon mal trostreichen ich glaube
dass diese neue Regierung sowieso einen
anderen Kurs eingeschlagen hat als die
alte sie ist vorsichtiger sie will die
Bevölkerung nicht noch zusätzlich in
history versetzen sie sagt bleib mal
ruhig lass uns mal beobachten wie die
Dinge sich entwickeln das war bisher
auch richtig wir hätten doch bei der
alten Regierung bei Herrn Braun im
Kanzleramt und Frau Merkel und Herrn
Drosten bestimmt schon wieder Lockdown
gehabt noch vor Weihnachten ein vor
weihnachtslok da und da hat ja schonmal
sogar Herr Lauterbach gesagt den will er
nicht mehr haben also ich glaube dass
die
Beteiligung der FDP an dieser Regierung
segensreich ist insofern und auch die
Ruhe die da neue Kanzler ausstrahlt und
insofern erwarte ich jetzt von der neuen
Runde die die am Wochenende Tag nicht
viel
und dass das beruhigt mich dass wir
nicht dass die Öffentlichkeit nicht
ständig während während das eine
Maßnahmenpaket gerade in Kraft getreten
ist oder noch nicht richtig in Kraft in
den schon das nächste in der kopfüber
das früher erlebt haben lasst uns mal
ein bisschen in Ruhe gucken wie sich die
Dinge entwickeln der entscheidende
Faktor ist wie viel Menschen werden in
Krankenhäuser eingeliefert und da haben
wir Hoffnung darauf dass Omikron weniger
gefährlich ist als das delta-virus